hey folks
welcome to the machine learning street
talk youtube channel today i'm speaking
with
mit phd dr keith duggar
we had a really interesting conversation
we spoke about interpretability
the dichotomy between inductive priors
and experience and machine learning
models
we also spoke about gpt3 and whether
it's reasoning we went through
one of gary marcus's articles there's a
lot of discussion at the moment
about whether or not a neural network
can reason what it means to reason
and keith was making an interesting
argument that any
reasoning conception can be unrolled and
can be turned into something like a
neural network
so why are they not reasoning it's
always a great conversation talking with
keith
are you a paper author would you like to
come and have a philosophical discussion
with us
please reach out to me on linkedin i
would love to have a conversation with
you
machine learning street talk does
exactly what it says on the tin it's a
street talk it's just a conversation
with
some random people and every single week
it's going to be a different set of
people
and we want to facilitate some really
interesting conversations
so if you'd like to be involved in
street talk reach out to us
remember to like comment and subscribe
we always really enjoy reading your
comments so make sure you
write at least something and we will see
you back
next week oh boy yeah i'm enjoying this
this book actually
but which one would have been because
what was it again interpret
interpretable machine learning oh what
have you read on it
molnar's books so yeah i've been looking
i like it for a lot of reasons
so it's a very good sort of survey
right of what's happening these days
what's out there
presented in a clean simple way i like
the
the taxonomy kind of section that lays
out
a very clear definition of all the terms
it almost strikes me as
somebody took part of their thesis and
published it as a book
so so for me i quite like it it's uh
yeah that's a beautiful book yeah and it
ended
how do i say this it strikes a chord
with me
because i think he doesn't shy away from
pointing out a lot of the limitations of
what's going on here
but i also i've also discovered some
at least from my perspective some
interesting higher level
thoughts about what's going on in this
book so for example he talks a lot about
if if we go to let's see what the
section is here
we go to properties of explanations i
love this section
that's a 2.5 because it sets up at a
high level
right what are we trying to achieve here
and the very first one
expressive power right expressive power
is the language
or structure of the explanations the
method is able to generate
an explanation method could generate if
then rules decision trees
weighted some natural language or
something else and that to me i realized
okay so we're trying to explain these
models
and we need some kind of language to
explain them
and i'm using language in very general
sense
just any kind of symbolics images
whatever we need some kind of language
right to explain these things to people
and
if you read on through the book and you
start looking at the
languages that are used to explain
these models they're all complicated
they're not layman's term languages
they're things like look at this box
plot
for example and see how it has bars with
different widths representing variation
and here's all the data points or the
feature points for a particular set in
the data
or check out these graphs see how
they're curving in this way or that way
they're all quite mathematical right and
in the case of the neural networks
the language that they're trying to say
the neural networks for image
recognition
the language that's being used to
describe them is
various kinds of images that vary in
form from
mind bending abstract
paintings or something to things that
just don't make any sense to a human
being at all
and so what's striking me about that is
that
are we really solving the problem here
we're going from one
complicated representation if you will
i just take the simple context of a a
linear model
here's my 0.127
of x plus 0.127 of x1
etc and maybe i can tell you what those
variables are but
it's a mathematical structure and then
we go and in order to explain that we've
got this other mathematical structure
for you to look at right
no i completely agree the first thing i
like
to articulate is that no machine
learning model is verbalizable
what we are dealing with here uh are
trade-offs i think one of the first
things that molnar said in his book is
that i've got a quote here somewhere
yeah
the problem is that a single metric such
as classification accuracy is an
incomplete description of most
real-world tasks
and it does beg the question why are we
making this trade-off can we have our
cake and eat it
the answer is no we can't because
models that are increasingly complex
have a
better predictive accuracy most of the
time and there are loads of trade-offs
as well so for example we're trading off
privacy versus accuracy
or fairness versus accuracy or privacy
versus fairness
or accuracy versus explainability or
even explainability versus security
so there's no right or wrong way to do
it
and these explainability methods they at
best give you a looking glass
into the rough behavior of a model
so i think a lot of the motivation
behind explainability if you will
for machine learning models at least a
big chunk of it
is to be able to get the public to be
satisfied with them or to be happy with
them or to be able to
justify to just an average citizen
why they didn't get their mortgage or
why they didn't get the grades that they
were expecting
to get on their you know uh a levels
right
so so if if we understand that a big
portion of our motivation here
is to be able to explain what these
complicated
complex models are doing to the general
public
we've got a long way to go because
i like one of the examples of there is a
decision tree
and i remember the first time i ever
looked at
a decision tree that i had fit to some
data set
i started thinking man this is an
arbitrary piece of junk
it's i've got all these nodes in there
if x is less than
0.153 and then further down if x is
greater than 0.11 and just like there's
all these arbitrary
sort of little cutoffs in there and and
there's a quote
in the i thought this is funny in the
book because he says
and that by the way nothing i say is i'm
not attributing any of this to
mulnar's personal beliefs i think he's
really presenting this in a very kind of
survey-like objective sort of way so
he's just capturing
right what the overall sentiment is
because i think he's i think i'm
probably on the same page
with him on a lot of things just reading
between the lines if you will
but he says in there about good
explanations
here trees create good explanations
the tree structure automatically invites
one to think
about predicted values for individual
instances
of counter factuals for example if a
feature had been
greater or smaller than the split point
right to me those are actually terrible
explanations
right like any time there's this
arbitrary
number that i'm looking at in isolation
like i'm looking at this node
man if only i had scored
89 on that test instead of 88.
i wonder what he meant by that
counterfactual thing
i think he's saying that some of the
more geometric inspired approaches
the decision boundary is a little bit
more esoteric and much harder for us to
understand
so for us to create a counter factual
example on a decision tree
we could quite literally pivot on one of
the decisions especially if it was a
categorical variable and
make it orange instead of red well that
was just like early example i just gave
you know i
i didn't get the a level i was looking
for let me see the decision tree
right and i go and take a look at this
thing and they look nasty to start with
but i go in there and i find some node
where i went left instead of right and
it says
grade on xyz exam greater than 80
88 and i look at that damn it
if only i'd have scored an 89
i would have gotten because you're
looking at this very myopic
isolated cutoff point there and in fact
there's plenty of tree below that
so it's not just that it was like
less than 89 and there's other things
below maybe that happened i don't know
i'd have to traverse the whole tree
probably complicated so my point is it's
deceptive like
going back to this kind of um you know
that there are deceptive indicators
or features that maybe sometimes we have
to ignore because they lead us down the
wrong path
it's a deceptively good explanation and
i believe people think it is because
they can find that one little spot
if only i had done this differently
right in this counter factual world if
only i had
i had done maybe if only i hadn't gotten
a divorce
right or if only i hadn't have had that
car wreck right then then something
would be different
and so it lets people focus on that
but i think in a deceptive way that just
makes them feel like okay now i
understand when actually they don't
understand
because it's part of this massively
complicated decision tree
that that's right and because i would go
a step further and many decision trees
random forests for example it generates
many decision trees and it takes the
mode over the results of all of them
so that's another layer of indirection
because you would be tracing down
several decision trees but also what's
interesting about decision trees is they
they're based on the id3 algorithm which
just cursively goes through all of the
attributes and looks at the shannon
entropy
and then it just selects the ones that
in order to give you the most
information going
and what's interesting as opposed to
deep neural networks is it doesn't look
at any interaction between the features
so it looks at all of them individually
and what may well happen statistically
is there's a kind of inflection point so
if you're if you're more than 25 years
old
that might be super important and 26
might be very different from 25
but if you were looking at the
explanation you might not realize that
yeah well
so i as an educated scientist i've sort
of been highly attuned to be
highly skeptical of arbitrary cutoffs
like that
because i know it's not i know it's not
literally
26 years old minus one day where
something magical happened
right it's more like there's a noisy
fuzzy population here
right and and maybe this was the
whatever 95th percentile
or something right and by the way that
can our that can change
depending on when we update the data
maybe today it's 26 years old minus
two days because we added a couple data
points but whatever
i know what's happening behind the
scenes there is this messy
fuzzy distribution and we've got a bunch
of people
who because of their location and this
bell curve
get routed off into some other part of a
decision tree
and and i tend to think i tend to think
with a lot of
variables in life that's a very perverse
way of structuring it i'd much rather
see a more continuous sort of thing
which is say
every day below age 26 you are
some factors it's in other words
regression
i'm much more interested in kind of
continuous regression approaches to
things
rather than these types of cutoffs there
are some things sure that it
makes sense to have a cut off have you
been in a car accident before or not
okay we don't really have data that
tells how close you got to getting into
a car accident maybe you've swerved and
avoided by
a couple inches 20 times you don't have
that data but the variable itself have
you been in a car accident i'm sure is
quite informative but then there are
these other things that we end up with
these cutoffs on
age number of children in the class i
was starting to think after our algo
shambles suppose that they decide to
continue using that algorithm
what we're going to see is people are
going to want to make sure all their
classes are 14 students
it's like a kid's gonna come and apply
because of that 15
cutoff in there i forget if it was less
than or less than or equal to let's say
it's less than
it's wow this is a great school jimmy
would really like to come here
we'd love to have him he scored well on
the test thing is we've got
14 students and we if we add them to
this class then we're going to hit that
15 cutoff
and all our grades are gonna be
diminished
so it's kind of like you know once we
get five more students
we can set up a new class that has six
people and then then jimmy can come
that's incredibly dangerous because what
you're talking about are the perils
of people gamifying the system
because you could argue that the system
needs to be
transparent everyone needs to understand
how it works
and decision trees are more transparent
because they essentially generate rules
they're verbalizable and they're
understandable
but the the problem there is that as you
say now
people are going to know that they can't
have 15 people in their class
because they won't get the grades so
maybe we should
stay transparent but we should update
the model
regularly so that doesn't happen anymore
now i think the answer is to get rid of
these kind of sharp boundaries like that
it shouldn't be it shouldn't be 15 it
should be something like some function
of the number of students let's say 0.01
times the number of students gets
subtracted from a grade or some
parameter and maybe that parameter
gets updated on a regular basis but we
just got to go to more we've got to go
to models that are
less discontinuous and i'm using
continuous a bit
loosely there because obviously we're
talking about a discrete variable on
that though
we could make a deep learning model
which was completely continuous and
more esoteric but we would still
reasonably need to explain to people how
it worked
so we would then use something like lime
or
there was something called lime anchors
by the way by marco rubio what that does
essentially is it
decomposes a model into a series of
if-then-else rules so it turns it back
into a decision tree
right yeah so then people just gain
again but that's
what i'm pointing out here is that it's
this odd thing that
trees if then else rules they're
deceptively
explainable but i don't think they
really are i think they're more
they give people a distraction you can
make them think
they understand what's going on because
they can focus on the one
one node that they regret in life
having done and that they could feel
like okay i get it
i had that car accident when i was 16
and that's why all these
you know things have happened to me but
it's really not the explanation
because it's actually this complex
decision tree
with a bunch of other factors so it's
just i think it's a
funny i don't want to say it's a paradox
because anything in life can be a
paradox to somebody
right it's more like just a curious
feature
of but in a way it's similar to
ourselves right we are
incredibly um biased in lots of ways and
we
confabulate so we see patterns where
there are none
and we delude ourselves that we
understand
the reason why we or other people do
things and
it's it's wonderful to see people do
this on the fly oh yeah that must be
because of xyz and you can just tell
their reasoning is faulty
and sometimes you don't want to pull
them up on it surely it's better that
there's some quantitative transparent
process
to deriving the reasoning
yeah and it's funny you mentioned the
the failings of human logic or lack of
logic or intuition because
that's actually again explicitly brought
up in the book here
there's a quote that says good
explanations
are consistent with prior beliefs of the
explainee
humans tend to ignore information that
is inconsistent
with prior beliefs the effect is
confirmation bias right
so we're all very familiar with
conservation bias
and conservation bias it's not good
from a logical perspective i i i forget
what the sort of
evolutionary psychologists say is origin
of it you may have been useful in the
past and maybe it could
still be useful i don't know but it's
certainly not logical
and yet we're saying that explanations
are good
if they conform to the faulty psychology
of people
and so we're almost telling ourselves
yeah the real problem with all these
sort of
machine learning models is they're just
too logical
we need to uh get away from logic and
start
incorporating some feeling and human
emotions into them and
that's what makes for good explanations
but if you think about it
we have a confirmation bias and it's
analogous to the learning rate and the
machine learning model
so we are programmed to learn quite
slowly
and to be quite conservative and to
assume what we know is right
and we've imbued exactly the same
behavior into machine learning
models yeah but not quite because in the
machine learning models
even though a new data point by itself
is obviously not going to have
as much weight as all the prior data
that you've observed
it has some weight whereas what happens
in conversation
confirmation bias is like people just
totally ignore it
and more so they when they're going out
to search for data points
they take all the data points that are
in this sort of analogy that you made
of low probability and truncate them
from the data set
and they keep all the ones that are high
probability and then those just become
part of the data set now so actually we
do something quite different in machine
learning which is we take
essentially every data point counts and
just because a data point is low
probability
doesn't mean it gets truncated and i'm
i'm a lighting that i understand there's
outlier
methods and analysis or something but
that's far
different from the way humans implement
confirmation bias if you went down to
just a few samples
say a dozen which is typically the kind
of samples that people are going to be
dealing with
when they're developing their viewpoints
or understanding a model or whatever
then it would have much more of an
impact if you removed an outlier
or and i say outlier loosely if you
removed a something that wasn't in the
normal
population of a data set of size 12
or 15 let's choose 15 that's what the uk
government likes
i like 12 but 15 gonna have a much
bigger impact
so i think that's we just have to be
careful with this analogy i think
confirmation bias in people the way in
which we implement it
is far more pernicious let's come back
to the explanations because
we want to have trustworthy explanations
we can also distinguish between
an explainable model and an explanation
an explanation is i've just applied for
a credit card
and you're the bank and you say no tim
you're not having a credit card
i say why and you say your um
debt ratio is greater than 1.2 and you
defaulted on a
mortgage payment last year and and you
would
quite factually enumerate all the
reasons why i couldn't get credit
that's right and that makes it quite a
transparent process and it would
would give me trust in the process but
it also complies that i mean
i'm fairly sure in banking they don't
really use machine learning for
uh credit and risk type applications i
think the distinction is made in the
book
so interpretable models versus
model agnostic interpretations so
there's work in one case you can look
into the black box
and see the parameters like you're
talking about there like there's the
decision tree
and in that sense it's intrinsically
interpretable because i can look at that
versus looking at it as a black box and
doing things like trying to come up with
prototypes or whatever the modern
terminology for all that is
lime or representative members et cetera
yeah it's so that's certainly true so
something like
a logistic regression or a generalized
linear model that would be
i suppose you could call it a white box
method so you're just analyzing the the
model on its own
and then there are surrogate methods
like lime for example which are
complete black box methods lime is a
local
model agnostic method so it means that
you perturb let's say it's a vision
classifier
you can take a single input image and
you can perturb it in lots of
semantically relevant ways
and you're trying to flip the switch on
the classifier
right or i think the example that was
funny in this book uh
spam filtering where if you see a
message that says for great christmas
deals come visit my site
uh smiley face emoticon then that 99
chance at spam and then what line did
was go in and just
try all possible combinations of those
were
combinations of the words taking out one
word
here or there the power set essentially
the ordered set of those words you're
like christmas deal
visit no not that one christmas deal
visit site yes that's
spam that sort of thing yeah but it's
really interesting because um
the reason why something like lime works
so well is
these models because line what it
essentially does is create a kind of
linear model over the perturbations of
a single input and
globally the model is very non-linear so
it's not you can't really explain it
in a linear sense but on a local method
when you're just taking a single input
example it does actually become quite
linear
the activations in the neural network
are surprisingly linear
so in the case of an input image for
example you what it does first is it
segments the image and then it creates
re
regions and it will just randomly mask
off some of those regions
so just make them grey and then yeah
yeah again so you said their lime works
really well i'm not sure it does
and that's what i love about it is he's
very clear about the
the disadvantages and you know what
you're just talking about there you can
imagine segmenting off portions of the
image
and masking them out or maybe uh
perturbing the pixels
there's such a huge
exponential land of choices in there
of how you're going to to do that that
augmentation or modification of the data
set right and fatty list is in his mind
what the biggest
disadvantage of this procedure is and it
comes back to the initial point which is
boy we're putting an awful lot of effort
into
mathematically modeling mathematical
models
and i'm just wondering if in a sense
we're chasing our tails here a little
bit
maybe we should focus more on
intrinsically interpretable
models but there is a fundamental
trade-off because
we've all signed on to machine learning
in the sense that
the predictive accuracy is significantly
better when
we lose touch of the explainability or
the verbalization
capability of the model so this is where
i'm going to challenge and get on my
normal soap box
so you made the comment earlier that of
course more complex models predict
better but the
complexity or adding more parameters or
whatever
isn't the only way to get better
prediction
and better accuracy so back to my
canonical parabola
case right sure we can fit a parabola
with
infinitely many values rectified linear
units and each one of those has
i don't depends on how you frame it but
say one to three parameters or
something like that you cut off a slope
whatever scaling
whereas if i'm somebody who just knows
x squared i can fit it with just a
single x squared
unit that has again some number of
parameters let's say
three parameters i don't think that's a
that's not a case of knowing
more it's a case of knowing different
and yeah and yannick brought up the
point yeah but if x squared what about
x cubed and into x to the tenth now what
so again a human being can know
something different there which is x to
the y
and now y is a parameter so i think the
key here is that we can improve these
models by bringing in
different not more which is that we
bring in different types of structuring
if you look for example let's say uh
what's it called in neural networks
where you find
the feature visualization right so you
you uh
i don't know you find the hot dog
or something like that that gets
recognized and you look at
the neurons that light up then you
create up images to optimize those
activation of those neurons and you wind
up with kind of these eigen faces if you
will the
images that represent that particular
feature and if you look through those on
neural networks
you'll find a lot of those are a feature
let's say a hot dog
yeah there we go that perfect so let's
find one that's i want to find one
that's distinguishing something
interesting like
wheels or so he's got an example in the
book actually this
let's if we go to let's take a look
at if you go to 7.1
there there we go if we go to figure 7.3
in his book there we go so let's look at
that one right there so
this is the activation that has
a high positive value for wheel versus
uh a high negative value for wheels and
you can see there what have we got we've
actually
got wheels on the left that are
translated and scaled a bit
so there's a big wheel in the lower left
there
and then it's it's got almost three
copies of itself that are
down scaled a bit and translated to
different sections of the image
and so you can see that neural networks
are really straining to do
affine transformations
yeah this is absolutely true i think
this is actually coming from the article
i was just showing you so let's just do
a quick
chat on that so uh this guy chris ollar
he's an amazing guy and he wrote this
distilled article about feature
visualization
and just to quickly describe how this
works so yannick has obviously made a
video on this he's made a video and
everything but
the idea is that you can solve
his light speed culture you can solve an
optimization problem
to create an input image that maximally
activates an output class or a neuron
inside your neural network or even an
entire layer inside your neural network
and when you look at what the optimal
image is that maximally activates that
layer or neuron or output class
you can then see the kind of patterns or
features
that part of the neural network is
learning and as you can see when you
look at
edges early on in the neural network it
tends to be learning patterns and these
look a bit like gabor filters which are
the kind of things that
computer vision engineers use to create
deliberately in early vision
applications
slightly later on on i mean this is i
think around the third layer
it seems to be learning textures and
then
patterns and then parts and then objects
as we go deeper in the neural network
there is a web page actually which
allows you to click through
this visualize for all of the res net
layers in
in an imagenet classifier i'll find that
in a second but and you can see here so
you can either do it on a neuron basis
on an entire channel on a layer this is
what deep dream is if you remember deep
dream so that was
optimizing across an entire layer on the
output class logits or the the class
probabilities
so you get some really interesting
results there
yeah yeah obviously with with cnns
so cnn's just by the way in which
they're structured
in a sense they they can handle
translation
okay scaling is more difficult for them
the higher up you go
in the layers becomes more difficult to
learn objects
scaled to different sizes but what i'm
saying here is
if we found a way to i don't know let's
say take neural networks and
double the number of parameters but have
them understand
affine and variance or triple the number
of parameters and have them understand
affine and variance that would be a huge
win so it's not the case
in my opinion it's not a case of
learning more
because a a neural network that
understands
affine and variants with a thousand
nodes
would in my opinion completely
outperform a neural network with a
thousand nodes that didn't understand
affine and i i should have said
parameters thousand parameters
versus parameters so parameter per
parameter if we understood things like
affine and variance just like if we
understood things like
multiplication or x to a power
it's not more it's different let's go
through the thought process because you
started off by saying imagine we had a
parabola
it wouldn't make sense to fit it with
lots of relu units
we we would take a parabola and
similarly if we had a fairly simple
predictive problem if it was a
regression problem
uh on a low dimensional data set we
could visualize the correlation and
it might just be something we could fit
manually and this is what data
scientists used to do they might just
fit some polynomial to it and sure
we're using the right tools for the job
but now we fast forward into the
unstructured
computer vision world and the reason why
cnns work so well is is they learn
features as part of the training process
which are better than any handcrafted
features because i think what you're
saying is why don't we
shortcut this process and do what
computer vision engineers used to do
and that was to handcraft features for a
particular domain
and that's something which has always
failed before but i agree with you that
when you take the example of that
bicycle wheel
we were looking at that bicycle wheel
and this let's look at this again this
is crazy right
because this looks like a total failure
this looks like
it's just a warped bicycle wheel that
and it's been statistically warped
such that it will match as many wheels
in the training set as possible
and the different conditions and clearly
if we were building a wheel
matcher probably by the way this isn't
just matching wheels it's matching other
things as well but mostly wheels
we would be able to come up with many
more affine transformations of wheels
than this this is all that the network's
come up with
yeah exactly and first of all i don't
think
image recognition works that well always
come back to this adversarial
image generation right that's just an
abject total failure
of image recognition okay if i can go
around town and put a little sticker
on stop signs in 20 years that suddenly
calls
causes all the self-driving vehicles to
go absolute mayhem and crash into each
other
that's an absolute abject failure of
image recognition
so it works only in the sort of toy
oh look at our resnet or imagenet
archive and whatever and
sure it works well in there but look as
a practitioner i've been out there like
trying to apply
image recognition and setting up a demo
for example and having
somebody walk by who because of their
features
was recognized as a garbage truck
not very good to have that happen like
when you're giving a demo
so i just i don't think it's working
well i think it's working very poorly
and i think
part of the reason why it works so
poorly is that we haven't taught at some
of the basics
about reality scaling rotation etc
and you brought up the case with sort of
the a little toy example of the
the parabola there if i was coding and
back when i was doing this kind of thing
i would actually just put into the
feature set different powers
of the input variables right so x
squared x cubed
and i would never really go oftentimes i
wouldn't go much above
x cubed because in the scenarios i was
working i knew as an engineer
that most systems in the real world
that i was working with all the
interesting kind of stuff
happened within powers 0 to three maybe
with some halves in there
so i might do 2.5 3.5 1.5
but it wasn't like i just added
thousands of powers like all powers from
x from 0 to 1 000 or i might put in one
that was a free parameter
y and then of course well i've now added
a new parameter
so i need to penalize that parameter
have some information criteria
or whatever so i think i'm just saying
we've got to teach neural networks to
understand some
really basic basic features of
the three-dimensional world in which we
live and i think they'll
perform so much better again just to
gently challenge you on that so i know
we've been talking a lot about
compositional
pattern producing networks because we've
been talking about open-endedness and
pick breeder and
we'll come back and talk about that on
another day but there
are things online that allow you to
visualize the results of a compositional
pattern-producing network and this
is a really simple neural network that
takes in takes in an x and a y
and it produces um a few color channels
essentially
so it's learning to mutate a very basic
neural network
as a function of its parents so you can
kind of like i quite like things that
look like that
that and that let's mutate and you see
what i'm doing and
this is what neural networks do they can
learn pretty much any function and you
said yourself that just given a few
powers well it's the same thing in
neural networks given a few different
activation functions and different
interactions between neurons
you can do some really crazy stuff you
seem to be making the argument that this
is
not fit for purpose no i'm just saying
we're not devoting
nearly enough time into researching
activation functions
and non-linear so everybody's putting so
much effort into just
how can i structure my layers
differently i'm going to
revolutionize neural networks by putting
some
cool layer in between these other two
layers that were already there and
now it's got a new name it's network 59
instead of whatever it was before
and this is just awesome all the efforts
going into that kind of thing like
tweaking layers and connectivity
and not much work into the actual
activation functions
like it's like we just have sort of the
same pool of the usual
suspects sigmoid relu whatever and also
not a lot of work is being put into
how can i create a layer somehow with
connections and activation functions
that's rotationally invariant or maybe
it's just rotationally invariant for
every five degree increment or something
like that
i'm just saying i'm not seeing a lot of
effort into those pathways is that
am i missing it even on this neat thing
so this thing i just showed you the cppn
it it's built on neat which is an
evolutionary
algorithm uh for finding uh neural
network topologies
and it will essentially compose together
any number of activation functions so
you can have all the trigonometric
functions
you can have all the the powers of x and
so on um
so it within reason it would be able
to fit almost anything because i think
you're arguing the toss over
should we evolve or learn some kind of
neural network structure
versus should we a priory
capture the structure about reality as
we know it
and should the layer structures should
we just trying to be
should we be aiming to be clever
in ways like yeah i'm going to have this
structure feed forward into
some other things because then it should
be more parsimonious or whatnot or it'll
be able to get a longer range or should
we really be putting in effort into
like i'm saying creating layers that
understand the basics of 3d
physics so how do i create like has
anyone
shown a structuring of layers that
produces a rotationally invariant neural
network
yes they have okay yeah
what about affine and variance i don't
know about affine but um i did a video
with ilya kamanov
earlier this year and it was called cnn
symmetries
and there are people so there are a
couple of researchers called cohen and
wellin and they are producing neural
network architectures that
provide various different types of
invariants
to things like rotation and scale and so
on
okay good so the rotation one what they
did
the first version would take the cnn
filter and it would rotate it
90 degrees four times so essentially
because the problem is with these cnns
we're wasting the representational
capacity right because if you
you rotate something by five degrees and
the neural network won't recognize it
the kind of cheating way of getting
rotational equivariance is by
creating copies of the cn and rotating
it so that the rotated one would
activate if the image was rotated
but then there was a more sophisticated
version using circular harmonics
oh right so i remember i remember
reading that paper actually
a little bit um i can't remember what i
found in there that was kind of like
yeah it's a step in the right direction
but it's not there yet
like the circular harmonics paper so
great those are great initial steps what
i'm saying is
there's not nearly enough effort along
those lines
in my opinion i think if we were
funneling a lot of the effort that we're
putting into just
building yet larger neural networks with
more compute nodes
and fancy kind of like arbitrary layer
constructions
if we actually funneled it into this
type of work or how to create
layers that are rotation and not by
doing it through data augmentation so
fine yeah i'll just take my image
and rotate it by 90 degrees and stick
all that data into an augmented data set
and then
lo and behold it will learn those no i'm
saying
structure layers that just already have
rotational variants
built in and yeah and this is definitely
it's the fundamental dichotomy between
priors and experience so at the moment
we are
completely biased towards experience
we have neural networks which are almost
blank slates
and they know almost nothing about the
world that we would
that we live in and even data
augmentation is just
another form of experience so we're
creating semantically equivalent
transformations and then we're feeding
them back into the blank slate model
but yeah and i'll have to often read
those papers again because
i think what i remember is that the
serial harmonics were computed at a very
early layer like it was we've got a
uh whatever four five by five grid and
we calculate
some function there that's rotationally
invariant but then see it's not going to
be able to learn rotational and variance
at higher levels of the layer so i've
got to do my homework i don't recall so
up until now and i will look in those
papers
i just don't recall any anything that
says
here's this clever layer structure
that's very close to being rotationally
invariant period
that kind of all scales something like
that yeah
because one of the trade-offs here is
the sample efficiency problem
because if we did have a neural network
that contained all of the priors about
the world we lived in
then we would only need to give it one
example as you said it would recognize
the hot dog
from all angles at the moment it's a
blank slate which means we need to give
it
loads of semantically equivalent views
of the hot dog
for it to recognize the hot dog and the
thing is as well it's it's not just
rotation and variance and scale
invariance it's also the manifold that
the world lives on
so for example if i took a picture of a
tree
that we're putting it into a cnn that
models everything on a planar manifold
it just sees pixels on a planar manifold
and a tree
in the real world actually has a
three-dimensional structure and the way
it reflects light and interacts with the
world around it
wouldn't it be good if the model had
some concept of a
cylindrical manifold to model that tree
that's what we do
we know that if someone throws a ball at
the tree it's a cylindrical manifold and
the ball will reflect
off in some direction so part of this
maybe is we need to build a physical
model of the environment that we're in
as well
a lot of that agree with you which is
that
no doubt adding some type of physics
modeling beyond just
some of the basic ones we've been
talking about newton's laws or things
like that can be very helpful
and then in addition and i haven't
looked at the research in this in
quite a while but obviously binocular
vision
is uh an important part of how humans do
that right
because we're able to construct this 3d
representation
in our mind and the cool thing with some
potential future of neural networks is
that they can go far beyond that like
with the self-driving cars it's not
binocular vision it's you know however
many cameras you install
and panoramic or and there's some laser
telemetry in there as well so they have
the potential to
the what's the word for that like multi
what is it
multi-something telemetry forget what
people call that you know anyway you
have telemetry from many different
sources
right coming back to because you were
raising the question of this
this motorcycle wheel and it's really
funny because when you look at this
wheel it makes you realize just how
crazy this whole thing is
because that motorcycle wheel is the
principal
piece of knowledge that neural network
has acquired about
motorcycle wheels it's actually slightly
topological because it's not a
motorcycle anymore it's a motorcycle
wheel
motorcycles have wheels maybe that means
that the wheel is the most instructive
thing about a motorcycle
and maybe it also means that it's a
shared concept with other semantic
objects that you want to let
but what it's done is it's taken the
real world given loads of experience and
it's composed it into a hierarchy of
shapes and textures and concepts and so
on and when you look at one of those
things that is that it's learned it
makes you think wow that's actually
quite one-dimensional
and i want to sketch out i was reading
this article by this chap yesterday i
did send it over to you and he's making
the same argument about
language models now uh i just discovered
this guys pretty interesting guy
walid sabha and he's saying your tech
giants are completely wasting time we're
barking up the wrong tree
and uh clearly he's so far no yeah i
could tell that he's one of these guys
from the from
the kind of marvin minsky generation
from the 1980s and ontologies and
logical reasoning and so
on good because that conception of ai
was modelling everything as
logical um symbols basically yeah expert
systems
exactly exactly and but i love this as a
critique of the current machine learning
movement because he's basically saying
that what we're doing is we're just
throwing loads and loads of
data from the internet into these
language models and
it's it appears that they're producing
something coherent but he gives a couple
of examples here of just how completely
crazy they are so there's a premise
and a hypothesis all of my friends are
married
the hypothesis is i have a friend who's
not a bachelor
okay so clearly the the hypothesis
follows from from the premise
and this is how you would construct it
logically
and what he's suggesting here is that in
our brains we actually
create a bunch of symbols and logical
reasoning over those symbols
and that's what we would expect a
machine learning model to do
so just reading this out now everyone
would agree that the hypothesis should
follow from the premise
if all of my friends are married then of
course i have a friend who is married
so we should get this result because of
that logical reasoning
thus if all my friends are married
premise then
i have a friend who is married
hypothesis must follow
but this is what you get so when you
stick that into
some of these nlp models it says that
the entitlement is 31.3 percent
and entailment means are they
semantically equivalent so the models
are failing
it says that there's a twenty point five
percent chance of contradiction and
forty eight point two percent chance of
it being neutral okay he said the reason
i want to show this example is to
highlight that entailment
which is the most basic textual
relationship cannot be done
by systems that do not allow for
symbolic reasoning if you try in
an example involving a slightly more
intricate relationship then you start
getting ridiculous results so here we go
premise a house is bigger than a chair
hypothesis
chairs fit inside a house right and and
here when you stick that through one of
these language models it says the
entailment is 4.3
so this is just completely crazy it even
says that it's a contradiction
so it's so easy to trip up these
statistical language models
and i would argue that this is analogous
to that bicycle will
right because all it's learned is a
bunch of statistical patterns between
words
based on a corpus of text that we've
given it
and what you're saying is let's have a
3d model and let's
create an environment where it's should
we call that spatial reasoning
because this is logical reasoning for
language
i think that's fair yeah spatial
reasoning yeah so there's definitely
a relationship there because i guess in
the context of
of the article you were just showing
saba's article i haven't read it but it
sounds like what he's saying is that
we need to teach these nlp systems
first order logic at the very least and
that if they don't
have that understanding of first order
logic
built in that they get into all these
sorts of silly situations
and i think it is analogous to
the image recognition scenario where if
we don't build in
the basic spatial logic of kind of the
environment or the world in general then
they get into situations where they
start doing
silly things because they've had to use
up
and they do things that violate that
spatial logic because they've had to use
up
all their free degrees of freedom to
learn
lots of basics that we could have taught
them structurally
and so that's why you end up with all
these sort of adversarial like that's
the way in which that
is demonstrated in in images because for
image recognition
pretty much the outcome is a
classification thing typically
what's the what is this image and those
adversarial examples serve as that use
case
it's exactly because because people
often ask the question what do we mean
when we say that humans can reason
and it's about being able to take lots
of disparate knowledge and
creating logical rules that generalize
in all situations so reasoning is a very
powerful thing
and when you look at that bicycle wheel
it's so obvious that
what it's done is it's learned a
statistical pattern that works in a lot
of situations but clearly it's rubbish
whereas when you have a logical um
proposition which says that
what was that house example yeah smaller
than a household
yeah chairs fit in a house that's just a
piece of
it's a fact it's a piece of knowledge
that will
generalize to every single
chair will fit into every single house
pretty much on this planet
that's a really useful piece of
knowledge but the
the problem is people have been trying
to create knowledge graphs for
30 years and they are brittle they are
expensive to create
they don't generalize very well so
what we really want is to have some kind
of an ai algorithm that will create the
knowledge graph for us
but possibly a balance we want to seed
it
we want to create some core knowledge
exactly and we also want to
learn more knowledge from a few examples
so that's what i completely agree with
which is that
and i obviously have some homework to do
on what the state of the art is for
things like
transformationally invariant neural
networks and
and whatnot but those paths are the
paths i think we need to put more effort
into
which is let's get this core knowledge
right
the basic facts about
the structure of the world get some of
that encoded i'm not saying to encode
all of it absolutely
not i'm just saying let's get a lot of
the basics encoded so for example back
when i was trying to do
engineering machine learning and
engineering context i just knew from
having
studied many papers and general kind of
knowledge that like i said
powers up to cubed are probably enough
and and then half powers in there and i
did pretty well with just those kind of
uh half dozen or so powers i didn't need
to encode
every single conceivable non-linear
relationship
and every single white paper out there
so let's just get some of the basic core
knowledge
really built into our machine learning
systems and then see what they can add
on top of that because i think it would
be fascinating
it's what would be if that image
recognition that found the
bicycle wheel if it understood
affine invariants so it could just do
scaling rotation
translation we don't even not even did
it we want to make it understand
uh rotation in three dimensions which
would cause it to let's say it did
okay what would it find i bet it would
find a lot of pretty cool stuff that i'd
like to see
rather than just oh yeah it's move this
around to four different locations
and or rotated it by 90 degrees like i
want to see what it can find on top of
some basic
stuff that we already know through and
through by the time we're
a young child
i know it's so difficult isn't it
because there's also recognition
versus representation yeah
absolutely and i don't know how much
neural networks
that's an interesting how much do we
believe neural networks
represent versus recognize
so you take that for example that wheel
again
obviously there's some combination of
weights and connections
in there that in a sense you could say
represent a wheel in fact that that
neuron itself
whatever if it lights up then that's the
representation of a wheel and then in
some higher layers
that representation can be reasoned
about like in the very simple sense in
which neural networks
reason by activation functions and
combining those
because to come back to the compression
thing we spoke about last week one thing
neural networks are very good at is
that network is just a hierarchy of
representations
and many of those representations are
shared particularly in the lower levels
entangled yeah exactly what if you
did explicitly and exhaustively describe
everything in our world would that just
be intractable
well
who knows i mean i i guess for me it's
for me it seems intractable
and and i'm not sure it's kind of the
way to go because i think as yannick
pointed out in our previous video
whenever we do encode knowledge we do
have to do
so like very carefully to always leave
an out for the algorithm to
deny that knowledge so if we encode that
the sky is up that's a problem we need
to really encode is that
in some direction there might be a sky
and and then actually would think about
it and who knows actually
there could be multiple there could be
more than one sky
in different directions zero one zero
one or n rule of computer science
there's either
nothing of something one of something or
an arbitrarily large
number of them and we have to consider
that and so we have to encode knowledge
in ways that provide these outs
so that whatever knowledge they develop
can be generalized
beyond just the limited context in which
they're trained
because we do have this concept that
intelligence
is somehow the ability to step outside
of the familiar domain that you've been
operating in
and at least have a chance of not
getting destroyed
having a chance of surviving outside of
that domain
yeah exactly and it does make me think
that
to what extent could that knowledge be
explicitly programmed for every
situation
i don't think it could because a lot of
intelligence is about being able to
adapt to new situations and
take existing knowledge and existing
facts and reasoning over them in a new
way
yeah it always it makes me think of uh
what is it the uh who was it that wrote
the unreasonable
effectiveness of of mathematics and
and science this is kind of i can't
believe i'm blanking
on the author but this is a very
fascinating
see unreasonable i know there have been
many papers
starting with the unreasonable effect of
so it must be uh
yeah but this is the the
eugene wigner yeah back in the 60s and
this has been thought about
a lot um since then maybe before but
isn't it bizarre that these sort of
simple and i'm not saying simple is easy
by the way
the simple and easy are very different
concepts for those out there i've got a
whole soapbox on that issue we can talk
about one day
but these very simple symbolic equations
that we develop
dx squared dt squared you know sort of
thing they work so well
for nature and isn't that a bizarre kind
of
scenario and so i think it is bizarre i
find it bizarre
personally and i know a lot of or i
found it quite mystifying i should say
and a lot of folks have as well and
leads want to think maybe the entire
universe
is a mathematical structure or things
like that but
let's not digress on that just now i'll
come back to that in a minute
if you don't mind because what i wanted
to say was just and answer your question
is it we've got to just find i think the
again the the core knowledge is a good
name for it the relatively small
subset of core things that we as
as a species have learned over the last
10 000 plus years of modern or
semi-modern thought and encode that and
then just see where we can get to that's
all
like these attempts to encode rotational
variants and things like that let's just
go
a little bit down that path focus some
of our resources there
get some nice layer structures and
activation functions and whatnot that
encode those
simple things very robustly
but what if it was not possible to
encode it
so again we're going full circle but the
reason why cnns for example works so
well
is no human could handcraft those
features now i understand what you're
saying you're saying why don't we
create some digital twin is a horrible
uh term but some kind of physical
simulation and some way of representing
knowledge and being able to
spatially reason over it we could do
that exhaustively
i'm not even sure that's possible well
i'm going to disagree with you again i
i don't i don't think cnns work that
well so i think
the the reason humans don't craft those
wacky features is because they don't
work well
in in the physical world and so we
didn't really need them maybe there were
some early species that
found the bungee ways of recognizing
wheels and they all died off so they're
no longer around so
i don't think cnns work well let me
sketch it another way
let's imagine that it is possible to
exhaustively describe
the world that we live in but i think it
might be computationally intractable so
let's say that we
we build a system to recognize any type
of object in any type
of scene as given to us on a 2d plane so
an image okay
and let's imagine that you took that hot
dog and you
did every single affine transformation
you tried to fit it through every single
part of the image
and you found a match in the bottom left
of the image
it would just be intractable to do that
wouldn't it so i
we have brains that do it so there's at
least that one example
of a type of computational device
some hybrid of analog digital
computation
it is able to perform it now depending
on kind of which side of the camp you're
on although the the human brain's
terrible compared to neural networks
when
you should think great then we've got a
good shot at
doing better than the human brain does
in a computationally
tractable way okay or maybe you're in my
camp that says look the the human brain
is
far underestimated in terms of its the
number of
its equivalence let's say in terms of
how big of a neural network and how much
cpu you would need to implement it
but i think it's not intractable we can
get there i think and maybe with some
clever
some clever work in structuring of
layers activation functions etc to get
them to understand not exhaustively but
just the basic core knowledge
of highly effective mathematical uh
and logical reasoning i think we can get
there i don't think it's intractable i
don't think it's going to happen anytime
soon
i'm not somebody that thinks the
singularity is 20 years away and i need
to download
my mind now or just give up and and be
happy until then
it's probably a ways off maybe
100 years or something like that but i
think we can
i think we can get there eventually yeah
because the challenge seems to be
going from a scene or a body of text
into some kind of representation
and it might be a physical simulation or
it might be
a bunch of symbols and their
relationship to each other and so on
because once we have that then we can do
almost anything it
the problem is though there are many
relationships in language that are just
they they can't be explicitly described
they are statistical they're context
dependent and so on
absolutely context dependence can be
described we've had
context sensitive grammars around for a
long time they're just
they're computationally much more
difficult than context-free grammars
and we do always run into this problem
of computational difficulties
for example being able to compute
marginals
right integrals over
more than one dimension for that matter
once you get into more than one
dimension it just becomes
way more difficult and when we're
talking about problems that have
in dimensions calculating those
marginals
is extremely challenging and of course
we have approximate techniques and
whatever
markov chain monte carlo or whatnot but
still at the end of the day
we just don't have the computational
resources to do what the mathematics
is telling us we should be doing if we
actually wanted the answer
exactly and that's a great example that
there was um a bunch of people from fair
that used a language model for
figuring out how to do integration
and it's a bit like the black art the
maths world there are so many different
ways of doing it and
funnily enough a kind of statistical
pattern recognition type system using a
transformers model
work quite well a lot of the time oh
that's an interesting paper
it's a we interviewed him a few weeks
ago and
he used a transformers model to describe
the the formula just in language and
then
he could just through continuation i
think predict the
result of that integration problem crazy
because that's the amazing thing about
language is you can describe anything in
language so if you come up with a way of
um describing a mathematical formula
you can describe that in language and
then you can get a transformer model to
solve it because you can train it on
loads of completions
loads of examples of solutions that are
known
and then it will learn interesting
patterns
in those completions and they've even
used it for
theorem proving so what was this
symbolic integration or numerical
like symbolic okay so i'm saying
computationally if you want to do
integrals that don't have symbolic
solutions and you're trying to do them
computationally so the marginalizing
probability distributions that comes up
often just use just trying to do those
numerical integrals
is just computationally not feasible
so we have to find kind of shortcut
methods so i'm not trying to underplay
the difficulty and and computation at
all
it's it's definitely a significant
problem
that that we face now always have faced
probably will face for a very long time
to come
i just would like to see a lot more work
along the lines of the
for example the rotational symmetry that
we talked about earlier things like that
i'd like to see a lot more investment
in trying to encode this core knowledge
robustly
into our machine learning structures
yeah i think it'd be fruitful easier
said than done
so gary marcus is the guy he's probably
the biggest
critic of deep learning right now he's
clearly in the symbolic camp
and this image it looks scary but it
does actually have some rhyming reason
to it which we'll see in a minute
but yeah he basically says that he's
really pissed off about the guardian
review of
gbt3 because they generated an article
of gbt3
but it turned out that they had an
editorial license and they
generated several versions of it and
they edited it together ah
they cheated yeah i hate the hype train
as a funny story i did that so
some years ago i used to be involved in
various
flame wars on usenet and whatnot and
there was one guy in particular that i
just
he he was just off his rocker and easily
triggered by
certain technological claims and whatnot
so i took a whole bunch of his posts
and used them to and i wrote my little
very easy markov chain sort of
generator that would try to create text
that was you know similar to his
i took a bunch of his post used that as
the training for that
generated a bunch of random text from
then did this editorial license
took out segments and pasted them
together i didn't change any of the
wording i just would take out different
paragraphs and sentences and thing and
and paste them together
and i got the guy to argue with that
that
monte carlo generator for free back and
forth
until he started to suspect like
something was up and
it was just got this coup de gras the
news group there like people
showing how this guy was just on
autopilot like arguing
with stuff that was totally nonsensical
yeah i wonder what his uh generative
model looked like
probably not much more complicated than
yours
but yeah so no i'm i'm very interested
in that and and
the papers about gpt3 and and the
criticism
uh that he's waging so definitely he's
on my list of
videos to watch okay on this article he
said that open ai have
not responded to his requests for
research access so
open ai have been incredibly selective
on who they give access to the api
and and uh clearly they didn't give
access
to gary that's not very scientific
is it that's kind of that's ant that's
antithetical to what we're supposed to
be doing
exactly so his his thesis here is that
it's all about the hype train
and open ai are interested in
commercializing it and building the hype
up as much as possible they're not
we're seriously interested in people
criticizing it and
he wrote an earlier criticism of gbt2 as
well but
it did well he also said open ai has
thus far not allowed us to
access despite both the company's name
and the non-profit status of the
oversight organization
so open ai
so yeah just like we said good
explanations are consistent with
prior beliefs of the explainee so openai
does not want
any criticism or you know it has to be
consistent with their prior beliefs and
clearly they know gary is not consistent
with their prior beliefs and therefore
they're going to ignore him
exactly it does make you wonder but it
says it seems to be a serious breach of
scientific um
it is ethics yeah i believe so
but they they did uh test a few things
here which i think
really highlight the limitations of gbt3
so one is biological reasoning
and so gt3 can just complete anything
you give it so here they said
you poured yourself a glass of cranberry
juice but then you
absent-mindedly poured about a teaspoon
of grape juice into it
it looks okay you tried sniffing it but
you had a bad cold
so you can't smell anything you're very
thirsty and it completes it you drink it
you are now dead
so yeah so um it seems to assume that
grape fruit
juice is a poison despite the fact that
there are many references on the web to
cranberry grape recipes that it's a
commercial drink
i bet you what it's actually doing there
and i don't know how much has been done
on the explainability of gpt3 but if you
go back to that paragraph
and if you're thinking more locally and
you just look at the
two sentences that came before the final
sentence right
you try sniffing it you have a cold you
can't smell anything you're very thirsty
so you drink it
that's you know there's probably some
crime novels out there that have that
same
combination of sentences in there right
oh definitely well this is exactly the
same remember that bicycle wheel
it's locality it's always locality it is
neural networks get sucked into
local should we say reasoning
or whatever local inference and it trips
them up
yeah exactly but this pattern of text
probably corresponds to
of course we saw a bicycle wheel earlier
but it would be something else in the
language world it would be
some kind of pattern which is being used
as an anchor
for represent for representing lots of
similar concepts it's almost like a
junction in a highway or something
and that's where it's going back to
physical reasoning
you're having a small dinner party you
want to serve dinner in the living room
the dining room table is wider than the
doorway so to get into the living room
you now have to remove the door you have
a table saw so you cut
the door in half and remove the top half
[Laughter]
so
yeah okay this is one confusion after
another the natural solution here would
be to either tip the table on its side
or to take the legs off the table if
they're detachable removing a door is
sometimes necessary to widen the doorway
but much more rarely
it wouldn't have been worthwhile for a
dinner party so all of it it comes back
to our core knowledge thing right
these are just basic things about our
physical reality that
if gpt3 knew about that it would be able
to we said last week you've got this
generative model but you need to
constrain and reason
over the information coming out right
it's clearly not doing that
so um we'll do another one social
reasoning you are a defense lawyer you
have to go to court today
getting dressed in the morning you
discover that your suit pants are badly
stained
however your bathing suit is clean and
very stylish
in fact it's expensive friends couture
it was a birthday present from isabel
you decide that you should
do them wear the bathing suit to court
you arrive at the courthouse and are met
by a bailiff who escorts you to the
courtroom so it doesn't know that
bathing suits are not appropriate attire
for a court
right yeah it doesn't know that you
probably have other clothing
besides just the suit pants yeah exactly
yeah so object and individual tracking
yesterday i dropped my clothes off at
the dry cleaners and have yet to pick
them up where are my clothes and then it
says i have a lot of clothes
so it's available there it knows there
it knows you apparently have
more than just the clothes that were at
the dry cleaner
yes it does
psychological reasoning what's that
janet and penny went to the store to get
presents for jack
janet said i want to buy jack a top
don't get jab
jacker top says penny he has a top he
will
didn't get a top i'll get jack atop says
janet and of course what it should have
said is uh he'll make you take it back
so it's not really reasoning over the
information but it does go to show
though that
of course it's not reasoning right it's
just a bloody hash table
how could it possibly be reasoning over
that information because if you think
about it like the forward pass
um through one of these language models
how could it possibly be reasoning
well that's kind of a philosophical
question right if it was simply a
memorization hash machine
and if you look at how it works in terms
of a forward pass that's what it's doing
it's going remember that bicycle wheel
it's basically finding the bicycle wheel
and retrieving it that's all it's doing
if it was trained on every possible
branch structure of this conversation
maybe there would be a bicycle wheel for
when janet didn't buy
jack the top so it would go and get that
bicycle wheel
yeah and on the one hand i'm tempted to
say obviously it's not reasoning
but we have to be a little bit careful
it's like in our last conversation
where i was talking about alpha zero
i i think some people would certainly
say that if you have a program
that has whatever a bunch of heuristics
doesn't matter whether
they're they come up with them by
reinforcement learning or human encoded
doesn't make a difference but
and it gets a position that it's never
seen before and it's doing computation
and evaluating moves
and chooses the right one a lot of
people would concede that is
reasoning and and i think you could even
formalize it to say that
it is reasoning say in the sense of an
expert system like
it's taking the data it's taking prior
statements facts knowledge um
it's deducing inferring et cetera it's
coming up with what it thinks is the
right move
now imagine that instead of that you had
a a black box
that some highly advanced civilization
came and dropped off
that literally was just a circuit that
actually solved
the p space complete problem of chess
so just you gave it a position and it
just was just a
a static circuit that evaluated it and
gave you the exact move
that was the the one to play in that
position is that reasoning
it's kind of like if i have a if i have
say an early
uh adder in a computer like an ad
an ad circuit that that has to do so
in more than one step you know it takes
several cycles to add or maybe
multiplication is a better example
multiplication it takes let's say you've
got a circuit that takes multiple
cycles right we can say that that's
computing
right it is computing on the other hand
what if i just have
a multiplication circuit that's just a
fully splayed out
you know uh nan tree that you that
that you just put it in and then the
circuit in one cycle gives you
gives you the answer is that computing
so there is
this weird kind of thing where we think
that static
static evaluations are somehow
fundamentally different than dynamic
ones that take course over time
and i think that's a bit of an illusion
i think they are the same
but everything you can do in a
programming language it's not just
conditional logic also
looping semantics and so on because in
that chess example
if the circuit could follow some
conditional logic it can say i'm in this
kind of situation
i have these threats i need to go and
identify all of the possible attack
vectors i need to
assign a probability or score to them i
need to loop through them i then need to
take the the best action which is blah
blah blah
if i could do that then that is
reasoning
yeah but so the point i was making like
with the multiplication circuit is that
any type of looping logic like that if
you have enough circuits can actually be
unrolled
so you can just unroll it into just a
single circuit that just calculates that
in a single flow of electrons through it
like there is
there's no need for actually that
temporal iteration
you can unroll all that make it static
but that's what a neural network is
i agree with you which is why i'm saying
that i don't think it's fair to say
a neural network isn't reasoning solely
because it's a static
mesh of activations this comes back to
charlay's conception of generalization
because understand if you unroll
then yeah it's reasoning but only in
that precise situation
but i'm saying there's an equivalence
between a program and an unrolled
version of the program they're going to
do the exact same they're going to give
the exact same result
for every input it's just one is a
static circuit
that does all its computation and kind
of a gate
gate flow of electrons in a sort of
single pass
versus having a state that evolves over
time
but at the end of the day it's the same
calculation being performed
and we have this bit of a bias almost
that if it takes you longer to do
something and you have to do it in steps
that's reasoning
where if you just had a bunch of
electrical potentials that
coalesced onto the answer that's that's
not reasoning
but isn't the difference one is very
memory intensive so one is enumerating
all of the possible paths
oh absolutely so that's what i said
earlier about enough circuits
when anytime you start doing this
unrolling you start to
dramatically expand the number i think
it's probably an exponential growth or
something
of the size of the circuit the number of
the circuits that's why we don't do that
for for all things that's why we have
programs and we have
cpus that are performing computation it
makes sense to
unroll certain things as circuits like
multiplication because it gets used all
the time
and we want to take place in one cycle
or whatever and that's great
but i totally agree that and that's
point behind
neural networks today and i think part
of the following behind them is they're
just going to larger and larger
unrolled loops if you will whereas what
we really need to do is other authors
have commented is
add on top of that some type of
computation
reasoning circuitry a hybrid between the
two
to get the most bang out of our our
circuitry
really yeah i agree but i'm just saying
philosophically like from a logical
point of view we shouldn't just
necessarily say
because something isn't doing time-based
iterative computation
that that's not reasoning you know
whereas
so if i have two equivalent circuits and
one does something by
iterative computation and the other just
has it all
splayed out in a static circuit they're
the same to me like
i don't see any difference in one being
intelligent and and one not
there is a difference because one can
generalize analytically to a lot more
situation
can it well you mean one technique like
in other words the
the iterative sort of those two circuits
are completely equivalent
let me give you an example so the
sorting algorithm
so you could create a function that
would for every possible permutation of
numbers
return the sorting algorithm is a maybe
it's a bad example but
you could write quick sort in about five
lines of code or you could just
memorize every possible input
i understand the difference and i
totally agree that
in terms of a certain number of
resources you can do
much more with allowing time to play a
role in doing iteration totally agree
with that
so i'm just saying that if i have two
circuits that are totally equivalent
you know if i have one computer has a
multiply circuit that does it in five
cycles
for a 32-bit integer and the other does
it in one cycle
they're equally intelligent to me
they're they're i can't say that
the one that does it in one cycle is
dumb and the one that does it in five is
smart
because for all inputs they produce the
same output
one is just a form of kind of
compression
that utilizes time i i don't know i just
don't i think there's a bit of a pitfall
here
or if we just start drawing a
distinction between
uh static computation versus uh
temporal computation i'm not sure that's
a valid distinction for all cases
it might depend what you optimize for as
well because we have fpgas for example
and
they are used for high frequency trading
and you can put neural networks on there
but
the trade-off there of course is
rigidity so now
yeah that's right they're very difficult
to program and they're very difficult to
operate and so on
i would totally agree as we said earlier
that
and so i'm not advocating that we just
go down this path of larger and larger
neural networks i think that's the
complete opposite path to go down i
agree with you we should be going down
these temporal
layers and computations etc i just want
to be a bit careful about how we define
what is and what isn't reasoning and
just make sure that it's logically
consistent that's all because
i point out with alpha zero if right now
it's reasoning
and it's intelligent does it suddenly
not become that once it's actually
seen and solved every position i don't
know yeah but i would argue that alpha
zero in a way it is reasoning because of
the monte carlo research it's looking at
all of the
possible future pathways and it's
dynamically
selecting a good one so it's many steps
if that makes sense it's imagining all
of the possible future paths
and it's selecting the best one
yeah i agree it's interesting so this
measure of intelligence paper i did a
thing about this and this was by
francois charley
and he said a machine learning challenge
to solve what is basically an
intelligence
test so there's a few more examples yeah
so
this would be an example so that goes to
that goes to that goes to that as this
goes to what so
we can clearly see what's going on here
we need to this is a pattern which has a
symmetry
we need to fill in the black box and we
need to output it
now from a machine learning point of
view this is bloody difficult and the
reason is you only have about three
examples of something
and then you need to generate the next
one so no deep learning algorithm will
work here
and in order for you to solve this
challenge you need to create an
algorithm which will know about all of
the possible
things that humans might do in this
respect now remember that the number of
the grid size is different as well right
so
here for example you would need to you
would need to know about symmetry you
would need to know about objects and
this is the same conversation right
because
a priory you could pre-code it with
every possible type of pattern because
what you're essentially doing
um he calls this developer aware
generalization which means
you're building an algorithm to solve a
task that you haven't seen before
and it's analogous because this thing
would have to be so efficient that just
given a couple of examples of something
it will learn the semantic pattern
and that's what we're talking about in
the vision world yeah because for
example
if you take a look at that just the
first image that just has the hole in it
right
you could pose this as how can i modify
this image to make it rotationally
symmetric
and then the solution is immediate right
yeah and
so if you had if you had a machine
learning algorithm that
understood rotational symmetry
then it's a question that can be posed
to that algorithm which is
search for an image
that's rotationally symmetric by
modifying these pieces
yep but there are so many variations
what what if it was a rectangle and it
was like a mirror symmetry through the
middle
you would just have to think of every
possible transformation and
the transformation is the word isn't it
because we were talking about every
possible transformation
in the image world yeah so it's really a
good way to phrase that
is transformationally invariant learning
is what we're trying to think about here
transformational variant learning
and and look i'm sure there are many
imaginable transformations and i have no
doubt
that we could construct intelligence
tests that lots of
humans would fail maybe all of them
would fail it because they didn't notice
that this was actually like i don't know
19-fold symmetry or something weird
that we don't think about but what i'm
saying is that and i bet if we went and
looked at kind of these intelligent
tests intelligence tests
most of them are probably from a box of
a very small
you know box of potential
transformations right and actually
so back in uh graduate school brain
teasers were
a really fun thing right we would always
kind of
exchange brain teasers give them to each
other kind of have a lot of fun with
brain teasers
and it occurred to me that what's
interesting is that brain teasers often
this
the solution to them kind of relies upon
like
a certain little thought or principle
right
could be whatever maybe it's the idea of
coloring like sometimes if you add
an extra variable to something like a
color you can solve the problem easier
so a great example in computer science
is the red black tree
you're trying to optimize a binary tree
if you add in this notion of coloring
things red and black it actually leads
you to a cool
way in which to keep the tree balanced
and so i call these prime thoughts
because in a way there's a thoughts that
every
problem can be factored into if somehow
you knew and or were
expert at applying every prime thought
that was out there you could be much
better at solving problems
but the question is are there
uncountably many
so look i i undoubtedly i'm sure that
maybe there are i don't know
there could be many there could be many
more than humans will ever know
but what i'm saying is that right now
the state of neural networks
deep learning and whatnot is that they
know none of them they sort of know
they know none of these prime thoughts
they know none of these transformations
and it's up to us to try and teach them
all that through data augmentation which
leads to this
overfitting problem because it just
needs an absurd number of parameters
and so my point is just that i think if
we start by just
teaching them a small number like how
can we
let's do transformationally invariant
learning with just
five transformations i think that would
already be
such a order of magnitude improvement
that then we could revisit the question
right because there's another example
here which is denoising
charlay makes the argument that we need
to have some kind of core knowledge
which would uh encapsulate all the
things you said because
in his conception of intelligence he
says that essentially
it's the generalization difficulty of a
task
in some scope divided by priors
plus experience and at the moment we are
balancing on the experience side of
things so what we're doing is we're
giving it
loads and loads of experience of
different permutations of the same thing
semantically equivalent
whereas a prior would be in viewing
knowledge about how to pass specific
semantic information
from this situation with less example
with fewer examples
yes i think i think it sounds like i
would be on the same page with that i i
made a video on it my most recent video
is all about this
we did a two-hour talk on street talk
about it and yannick has made four
videos about it
so but it's called on the measure of
intelligence this paper
clearly we're all big fans of it yeah
yeah yeah yeah so what he's calling core
knowledge or or what
what i call prime thoughts long ago
that's the point
is that we need to we've got to encode
this basic
prior knowledge otherwise we're just
we're asking the networks
we're asking the deep learning networks
to do
a lot of busy work that we could have
just told them up front
and and let them focus more because like
you were saying every lens is just
creates a spherical manifold and we
project it onto a
2d surface i actually have no doubt that
if you had a neural network
that understood affine and variance and
whatnot and
also was able to calibrate for that
which is obviously more advanced than
what a human being is going to do when
they look at a
2d image i'm sure it would have
applications
right whether it's in yeah the medical
field or
or x-ray image analysis or military
targeting systems like who knows like it
would have
very cool applications i agree i think
the problem is computationally
it would involve so many different
transformations that it might be
computationally intractable
but well this has been amazing i hope
you enjoyed this episode of machine
learning street talk
we will see you back next week